I did it for him and was a happy feeling
yeah I think the whole football world
knows the situation so when that
happened everybody was a shot was a shot
this is tribute was for our friend
Abdullah glory we call him happy
he played together with with epi that is
a good friend more as a brother for us
for everyone I think involved with him
as I exhausted when we were younger I
always thought like tournaments abroad
and I be always one like player of the
tournament it was always one of the best
if not the best in a team because I
chose the pineal Lord to literally keep
the cost down shall we said no you P
really kind of visual means if a much
more pain he always played with a kind
of flair and the part is he gave were
unbelievable only he could see them
understand why they compared with mes
and we've got some rather sad news to
bring you now I play the friendly
against Werder Bremen preseason and he
collapsed the scale Jackie PE wanna
swallow match promising 20 year old
Dutch footballer was put into an induced
coma at a hospital in Austria after
collapsing during the match when the
iakhs midfielder has been left
permanently brain damage no they forgot
to accept that this did happen to me
that I chose to do two college degrees
for me it was over me
I'm a portal Club the logics cosmos
Rashidah Vermont history
[Music]
I play with the number 34 on my back
that's what my friend
you can see that everyone is thinking
about it and everyone plays without
being as hard the pretty [ __ ] also
recruited the Nova Scotia so when you
see Sofia mental on dog it's just a way
of expressing how you feel about the
situation the respect that you show your
friend and show the love for him I think
it means a lot to his family to see how
much people care about Abdullah strikes
on franceour official care dr. cassandra
food new people movie we were super
meaty to jocular Sofia please II kind of
like so much to see a community
so take it that's what happened to happy
the way I looked at life I was just like
just be happy and do what you can do
because everything can change in in a
second Eppie was so gentle so respectful
a guy full of passion when somebody is
so special or we will never forget him
[Music]
Oh